would you go back on the picket line
look I'll always listen to my
constituents but no no but but I want to
be absolutely clear about this my job is
to be in Parliament holding this
government no I understand but you the
leader said don't go on the picket line
and you did I'm asking you would you do
it again look I'm not I'm not I'm not
you know I'm not going to be on a picket
line next week or in the coming weeks
I'm going to be in Parliament doing my
job and actually I've never gone out and
picketed because that is not my job I've
been a member of parliament now for 12
years I've always met with my
constituents I've always listened to
their concerns and when they go on a
picket line I know that they do it as a
last resort but that's their job my job
as their Member of Parliament has always
been to go out and fight for wider
changes that's what I've always done and
that's what I'll continue to do did he
speak to you about it I've you know I
speak to kirst armor all the time but
we've spoken about the issue about the
strikes about pay demands and about pay
negotiations and we are a hundred
percent on the